from CNN Biden asks if deceased
congresswoman is present at White House
food and security conference does this
do it for you is this a more apocalyptic
the president who a month ago paid
tribute to a congressman who died
seemingly forgetting he did that a month
later calls out to her and says is she
here where is she I guess she's not here
I guess not huh just a week and a half
ago
he was on 60 Minutes and he asked him if
he was mentally and physically fit to
serve office and he's like oh I'm oh I'm
focused oh I'm focused and then two
weeks later you know
he's uh he's like oh where's the dead
congresswoman yeah I mean oh my God like
come on that's it he's undermining his
own argument oh yeah I'm oh I'm I'm in
good shape I'm in good shape I'm 80. you
know it's it this isn't he all he may
almost total Clan world he may be the
only person who doesn't realize I mean
that's how
brain Decay works you know you're not
aware you don't have any nerve endings
in your brain you don't feel any pain
from it so I don't think we should be
asking him if he has brain Decay that's
not how it usually you don't ask a
person with dementia if they have
dementia but everybody else around him
is is like their his yes man that's
correct he has two metal stints inside
of his head holding back major major uh
what is it aneurysms
um so he is not in good health but he
has his finger on the button to
literally blow up the world 20 times
over he could do it any moment anytime
according to the official story of how
the government actually runs and how the
president is in charge and the
commander-in-chief which I question and
I think his his decline perfectly shows
what I think is what is happening behind
the scenes of just the front guy that
they're pushing forward to blame for the
acceleration of the great reset let's
put him up forward let's blame
everything on this cognitive decline
meanwhile the richest most Sinister
people behind the scenes are grabbing up
everything for themselves and pushing
them most absurd policies that no
president would ever want to be known
for so but I want to I want to give a
shout out to CNN because
um you know I I this headline is amazing
Biden asks if deceased congresswoman is
present at White House food in security
conference they could have spun that A
Million Ways well they did CNN did yeah
they did there was uh there was actually
let me find it it was an other
uh article too let me give me one second
I just like I like I like how they
framed it when Kareem Jean-Pierre was
asked she was like well clearly uh to
Joe she was top of top of mind she was
off top of mind and I'm like what is she
saying what does that mean Joe Biden
called out to a woman who is no longer
living and then asked if she was here
and said I guess she's not it's like bro
do you remember that you paid tribute to
her like you wrote a letter I guess he
didn't write the letter don't you think
that that going back to what we were
saying earlier you know is there a
certain breaking point at which people
wake up don't you think any sentient
human being saw that would be like yo
that's BS
person of the White House is is
literally lying in front of me oh but
but it's been happening look come on
Russia gate if you still believe this
stuff just I'm I'm that's why I'm saying
it's a good point you know there's a um
we talked about this a bunch of times in
the past when we get into our weird and
wild Shenanigans shows but I was like
there's some religious Theory or a
theory is the right word this idea that
there's a finite number of Souls and
that some people are born without a soul
because let's say there's only a billion
Souls available so when more people are
being born there's people who don't have
any Souls because there's not enough of
them I'm not saying I believe that but
that's you know conversation we had the
argument then becomes if only that means
one in seven people are just mindlessly
drifting about without any sentient
function you know what I mean
like dude at what point do we say
someone is cognitively deficient if they
believe this stuff you know what I mean
that's a I mean that's a good you find
the article it's a question of what
reality is and how it's being fabricated
yeah uh the the article is Joe Biden's
latest gaffe plays right into
Republicans Republicans all right was
that an opinion piece though uh it's
under CNN politics so I mean it's it's
announced I guess but this this one's
like their actual news article and they
just outright say it he asks if deceased
congressman is present like I think I
feel like that's a very harsh framing
it's hard to ignore it though it's hard
it's it's hard for a news organization
to actually spin that and go like like
NPR somebody pointed out the NPR did a a
piece on the event that he did and
didn't mention the the Gap at all how
much do you want to bet he really thinks
kamla is the president
you know how he's like called her
president several times yes like they
just he look he was in the basement the
whole time the campaign was going on for
all we know they came downstairs and
said congratulations Joe your VP again
he was like oh oh gray who's President
camel is like oh all right he's called
Doug amhoff the first lady
I'm not I'm not kidding I'm not even
making a joke it's it's true story I
kind of feel like you know at what point
do we just sit back light up a cigar and
and you know ride the the gravity bomb
down I thought that's what we're doing
yeah yeah since January 20th I will say
though having my dad uh suffer from
degenerative brain disease over the
course of a number of years it's
interesting because kind of your core
nature comes out and like all the core
habits you know like needed a cup of
coffee like you you stick to the things
that you really know that you can rely
on every day you're with teens but for
him it was like the opposite it was like
he was so unwilling to give up his
independence that any time that you try
to help him with anything you know he'd
be smacking you away I think Joe Biden
was just complicit in this stupid game
from the beginning and so now it's just
like It's Just Happening easier you know
you just just kind of cruises yeah
people were saying on Twitter that this
is was it sundowning but it's getting
worse if it's to the point where like it
was a month ago that he sent out a
letter being like tribute to walorski's
family and I think that's our last name
and he doesn't even remember that it's
just like come on dude that's it's worse
it gets worse they actually had a
tribute to her at the event yeah so here
he's coming out to speak this event that
was actually going to do a memorial
tribute to her and he asks if she's in
the audience like this might not be
dementia this might be something
substantially worse than that like it's
one thing that your brain stops working
you're forgetting things and you're
confused it's another thing when you're
like putting Concepts together that
shouldn't exist like we're paying
tribute to this woman who died is she
here sitting in the audience somewhere
like yeah there's no way he's in charge
he had major brain surgery a number of
times being the president of the United
States is an extremely exhausting
stressful job that many presidents age
severely during their time in office you
look at the presidents uh maybe you know
people make arguments against Donald
Trump but you look at Obama you look at
Clinton you look at Bush they look like
totally different human beings before
they came into office and after they
came into office as years off of their
life have been taken away there is no
way he is slaving away there's no way
he's at that desk making the decisions
he's not in charge he's not calling the
shots the bigger question that people
need to be asking themselves is when
he's not there he's checked out he can't
even make coherent sentences who's
really in charge that's the question
that a lot of people should be asking
them Easter Bunny can we give a round of
applause to the onion
I love to bring this article up that's
great the stress of presidency already
ages by in 10 years and it shows
so so who's in charge if it's not if
it's not Biden who's in charge who's
calling the shots here who's who's at
the desk right now with that button that
could blow the world over 20 times over
it's Ron Clane it's Jake Sullivan it's
definitely not Kamala Victoria Newland
BlackRock and all these other multi
Goldman sacks and all these other
multinational corporations that are
obviously benefiting greatly from the
policies that he's not even putting into
place but he's signing on to and saying
yes I'm for it when in reality I don't
think he's there well getting back to
the actual Gaff people don't they they
don't understand because the White House
is spinning it in a way that they're
like oh well she was on his mind a top
of mind and that's why he said it but of
top of Mind top of Mind of top of mind
he was of top of mind I don't know what
that means like that I don't know I get
what you're trying to say about where
that phrase comes Steve Portnoy from uh
CBS News I think CBS News CBS News Radio
he said he said look we just want to
understand what happened here like can
we see the prep Were You released the
prepared remarks because it's possible
that you know to be completely objective
here it's very possible that in the
teleprompter it said you know I want to
say thanks to these people that helped
push the bill through
and they didn't put the late Congressman
or the late congresswoman or whatever
and you know like actually just spelling
it out for Biden and he just kind of
I mean just pulled a Joe Biden uh but
she was but the answer was why do you
need to see the prepared remarks we put
the delivered remarks up on our website
so it's it's very possible that somebody
made a mistake in a teleprompter but I
mean ultimately Joe Biden made a mistake
Ron Burgundy he just reads whatever from
the problem but you really need like
that's why I had the card remember the
card that he had where it said walk it
through the door sit down you you know
you do this you do this the reporter did
you see the one with the reporters
pictures and names and news organization
and question and answers that they were
supposed to be given and having the
interaction with all of that yeah and
they give him cards with with little
thumbnails of the people that he's
getting in huge print with big photos
very simply laid out there you know we
we sometimes do promos for emergency
food here on this on this show and I'm
on my other show and right now I got
this big hurricane barreling down in
Florida and it's it's crazy I mean the
uh the water on the Northern and part of
the hurricane although all the water was
was pushed out so like the water drains
because the wind is pushing the water
and then on the south end of the
hurricane it's it's actually a a 18-foot
storm surge just flooding Fort Myers is
brutal and stories like that when they
come up I'm like guys you really need to
consider this emergency food yeah
because people are going to get trapped
in their homes for up to 10 days with no
electricity and so have you have you
thought about what your emergency
supplies are do you have canned food do
you have supplies do you have water
you're gonna be able to drink so
especially if it floods like what are
you gonna do where you're gonna go now
now that story it's obvious to most
people like why you would need emergency
food but I gotta tell you this storm
it was a hurricane and our president
doesn't know what's going on no I mean
like Bad Company If the perfect storm so
if a commercial came on and they were
like a storm a hurricane could strike at
any moment right now there's a hurricane
buy emergency food I'd be like yeah you
know I get it whatever you show me this
and you're like the president can't
remember if you know that he paid
tribute to a congresswoman who died I'd
be like
oh boy as we're severely escalating
tensions with Russia and trying to of
course make sure that the conflict in
Ukraine is prolonged it's absolutely
Bonkers to to be in this current
situation not just because of the
natural disasters but the human
disasters that are happening in places
like Philadelphia places all throughout
the United States were havoc criminality
and lawlessness is just the new Norm
which is which is again just perplexing
to see such a destruction and such a
chaos within our society and I think a
lot of it is deliberate and speaking of
the hurricane
that story the hurricane is actually
drowning out it's it's
covering up this story like this this is
being pushed back you know I'm just in
all seriousness when the president has
displayed this okay first of all we just
had what a couple days ago where he gets
lost on stage and he's doing the Mr
Burns yeah where he's like walking
around confused and then I was I was I
was covering that and so I looked up the
Cornholio fists remember during the town
hall he's standing there with his fists
clenched like Beavis and with no
explanation everyone's like what's he
doing like something's wrong with this
dude yo
Vladimir Putin is now accusing the U.S I
believe Putin formally I could be wrong
but I believe the US is now being
accused of uh sabotaging the Nord
pipeline Tucker Carlson came out with a
great segment last night wait wait wait
more in depth than the one I put out
pointing out that not only did this leak
occur with two explosions detected on
the Nord pipe North stream pipeline but
the Baltic pipe was just announced the
same day coming from Norway to Poland
right at a very very close to where the
north stream line goes in right so it's
it's like similar clearly sabotage of
some shape or form greatly benefiting
the west and our president
commander-in-chief this is this is the
brain he has I I gotta say I I think you
know it's it's like a chicken with his
head cut off thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special will access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there